and for some perspective on all that's
going on we turn to end gear in a White
House correspondent for the Washington
Post and good morning first of all how
much confusion is there right now at the
border about implementing the policy and
how much confusion is there in the White
House about this policy there's there's
confusion in both places for sure at the
border the the Customs and Border
Protection Agency is uncertain exactly
how to implement the president's order
from Wednesday which reversed his family
separation policy what are they in
certain about exactly well they're
uncertain about how to follow through
without coming up against a federal law
that says you can't detain children for
more than twenty days the the
president's order is unclear about what
you're supposed to actually do when a
family presents itself at the border i
if the children will not be removed from
their parents then presumably the entire
family will be detained together the the
government is asking for an exception to
that law it's not it's not at all clear
that they will get it and so there's
there's a fair amount of uncertainty and
confusion which has caused arguments
back in Washington about why this wasn't
settled ahead of time and and what
agents are supposed to do at the White
House there continues to be a policy
argument and an unresolved one they we
saw spilling over into Congress
yesterday it's clear that there's not
something some big thought out strategy
along those lines the president even
said told Congress not to waste their
time in a tweet so now what type of
uphill battle is that going to create
for lawmakers trying to at least get a
compromise villain it makes it much
harder I mean the the president took an
already difficult task in recruiting
that moderates have in the house and in
recruiting enough votes to pass this
measure next week and made it in
considerably harder the president is
telling the Republican Party to set
aside an immigration until after the
midterms which is something
that moderates do not want to do and and
they say that that only plays into the
hands of Democrats who will make
immigration and the confusion those
those images those those sounds of
children being separated from from their
parents
a potent issue in the midterms and in
terms of how we got here I mean the
president's hardline on immigration is
nothing new the zero tolerance policy
has been in place since May so what was
it that caused the tide to turn what was
that tipping point well I mean the
President had a mutiny on his hands of
among Republicans even within his own
family within it advisors and he
recognized by Wednesday that he needed
to change this policy or the the the
pictures the images the the visuals the
the you know the entire storyline that
was turning against him was only going
to get worse so he wanted from Wednesday
he wanted to act and you know that he
you saw in his wife's visit to the
border in things his daughter Ivanka
said that he was getting a lot of advice
from pretty close at hand that he needed
to make a change
Ann Guerin we appreciate the insight
thank you